[Music]
I got a call from my manager saying that
Taylor Swift wanted me in her upcoming
music video I thought it was a huge joke
and I was I was just like why are you
making something up like that like well
I was like this is so this is so
incredibly random like what what but I
didn't know what it was going to be for
What the song was gonna be what the
project was gonna be from the names of
the songs I narrowed it down to either
lavender Haze or midnight rain because
of what we filmed so at what point do
you find out that it's lavender Haze is
it the day you walk on set no I found
out that it was lavender Haze and a few
days ago when she released the video I
didn't know what tell me it was
wow yeah
working alongside Taylor and watching
her in a directing capacity what was
that like for you what kind of director
was she she was really sweet very kind
she storyboarded the whole thing she
wrote it she knew exactly what she
wanted scene by scene shot by shot one
thing that I thought was really neat was
that uh after every take if I was in
that particular scene she would let me
take a look at the monitors as well so
that I can see what I looked like which
is it's not normally done so I thought
that was really awesome she moved her
hair out of the way showed me the earwig
in her ear and let me know that I
wouldn't be hearing the song only she
could hear the song and
um that was the thing is Taylor doesn't
have to use her platform what does it
mean to be in a video with a mega
Superstar but also be representing the
queer Community it's huge I mean as far
as I know I'm not 100 sure but this is
the first time a trans man is playing a
lead love interest in in media in
general so that's major and uh My Hope
for that is that it opens doors and film
and television to tell those types of
stories I think that because I look the
way that I do I'm not visibly trans
necessarily so I know that for that
reason maybe my appearance might be more
easily digestible for CIS hetero folks
me speaking my truth and speaking about
my experiences would hopefully only open
the door for other people within the
community to do the same and for her to
be as big as she is and to allow me it's
like a gift for me to be seen and be
visible it is a big deal and it it's
I've gotten so many messages from Young
trans people
[Music]
I'm glad that she's essentially loaned
me that platform where I can speak on on
my one my experience but also
um help with visibility for the entire
community
hey thanks for watching ET Canada if you
want more queer entertainment news and
exclusive interviews be sure to
subscribe and check out these videos